[Music]
on this friday night ontario's new
border restrictions with quebec and
manitoba
as the stay-at-home order is extended
with coveted cases expected to hit
all-time highs more people are going to
die more people are going to be in the
icus
plus the younger patients hit by this
brutal disease
my stomach is like paralyzed because of
having
a 13 year old boy shot and killed by
police the deadly encounter putting more
scrutiny
on policing and the eve of the final
farewell
to prince philip he's getting the
funeral he really wanted
but will all eyes be on william and
harry
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill canada continues to face an
incredibly serious situation
with this third wave cases are rising
rapidly
in many cases in many places numbers are
higher than they've ever been before
and far too many hospitals are stretched
way too thin
good evening and thank you for joining
us the weight of this wave of the
pandemic is hitting hardest in canada's
biggest province
today ontario announced new measures to
try to slow the spread of the virus
it comes down to tooth ring three things
limiting mobility
enforcing the rules and getting vaccines
into arms today ontario shattered
another daily record more than 4800 new
infections
new modeling shows it could get a lot
worse peaking at nearly
20 000 cases a day but the biggest
problem we now face
may be that we're just too tired to
notice so i'm begging you
as part of the team to notice notice
that our hospitals can no longer
function normally
they are bursting at their seams we're
setting up field hospitals
and we're separating critically ill
patients from their families by
helicoptering them across the province
for care our children's hospitals are
now admitting adults as patients
and this has never happened in ontario
before it's never happened in canada
before
the strain on the hospitals and those
dire projections are forcing the
province to finally put in restrictions
that doctors have been calling for
for months here's eric sorensen
restrictions are all around us
the shuttered storefronts people masked
and not gathering in groups
workplaces with safe distances all the
measures so far
have not been enough the sick continue
to come in or be brought into hospitals
many health centers bursting at the
seams we've never seen ice use this
packed
and and the trajectory is still going up
so the province is now bringing in yet
more measures the emergency stay-at-home
order is being extended now to six weeks
outdoor gatherings limited to families
only an exception for people who live
alone
and checkpoints at all interprovincial
borders as well
non-essential construction sites will
close capacity and big box retail will
be reduced
churches will be down to 10 people
inside only
and new restrictions on golf and outdoor
recreation
ontario's premier says simply the covet
variants are winning the battle
the pace of our vaccine supply
has not kept up with the spread of the
new coved variants
we are on our heels but if we dig
in remain steadfast
we can turn this around the picture
grows more dire
the number of people in ontario
hospitals with covid virus or variants
is now approaching 2000
ontarians in intensive care now total
over 700
an unheard of number and yet the
projections show icu cases will rise to
800
soon and whether moderate measures or
new stronger measures
icu cases are expected to top a thousand
and go as high as 1500 next month
before leveling off for you know the
next week or two those numbers are baked
in that's not going to change that's the
nature of the disease
ontario has put out requests for nurses
from other provinces
alberta and saskatchewan have both said
they just can't spare any
so we just don't have the the capacity
to
start even talking about loaning
our health care workers out for a period
of time to other provinces
some are flagrantly ignoring health
measures like anti-lockdown protesters
around one
gym in mississauga but health officials
say all ontarians have to do more
and not try to get around health
restrictions more and more people are
sort of saying
i think i can work around this and just
play it by ear
a bad decision and you need to be very
careful ontario health officials are
calling for more vaccines for high-risk
communities and essential workplaces
but that too will take time the bottom
line case numbers will get worse before
they get better
it's unavoidable eric sorensen global
news toronto
canadians are just so frustrated over
the slow vaccine rollout in this country
today the federal government announced
it has secured eight million additional
doses of the pfizer biantic vaccine
that's on top of what's already been
purchased prime minister trudeau says
pfizer will make up the bulk of
vaccinations in the coming months
the supply from moderna will be slashed
in half for the rest of april
the pharmaceutical company is grappling
with production issues at its facilities
in europe
canada's initial shipment of the johnson
and johnson vaccine
about 300 000 doses is expected to
arrive the week of april 27th
and it will be distributed to the
provinces at the beginning of may
vaccination is just part of the solution
canada's doctors are calling for
extraordinary measures
to curb the crisis that's unfolding in
several provinces
david aiken reports on how the federal
government is responding
canada's doctors are sounding the alarm
we're very very near if we're not
at that point where dire decisions
gut wrenching decisions are going to
have to be made at bedsides
about you know who's who essentially
who's going to live and who's not going
to live here
the crisis may be worse than ontario but
several provinces are scrambling to deal
with
rapidly rising case counts british
columbia is already surpassing all-time
highs in terms of new daily cases
hitting
1200 this week and on its way to perhaps
3 000 a day and the curve is spiking up
in alberta with more than
1600 new cases a day now being reported
and in quebec there were 1500 new cases
yesterday
that can't continue and if
if what drives that does continue then
yes those
critical
life and death decisions will have to be
made and so the canadian medical
association is calling on the federal
government to do
more to put stronger public health
guidelines in place
to overhaul sick leave programs so that
workers who are sick or who are living
with family members who are sick
can stay home and to revamp
vaccine priority strategies but ever
since the beginning of the crisis and
again on friday
prime minister justin trudeau resisted a
starring role for ottawa
in favor of playing a supporting role to
decisions that he feels
provinces have to make to help and what
we have said repeatedly
to all premiers is that we are there to
help
whatever is necessary on friday
trudeau promised to send ontario
federally funded red cross
mobile vaccination units and other help
that he said ontario had asked for
and yet ontario's premier said his
province did not need the red cross but
they do need more vaccines more vaccines
means fewer cases more vaccines
mean fewer hospitalizations and more
vaccines
means we get out of this sooner and
there's even talk of
army medical staff being sent in to help
overwhelmed
hospital icus the problem there global
news has learned that
the army does not have much backstop
capacity
with only 73 critical care nurses
available
in the entire military david aiken
global news
ottawa tonight we want to remind you
that behind each case
there's a human story you're about to
hear from young people who got
so sick from this virus that they didn't
know if they would make it
but they did survive and tonight they're
sharing their experiences with heather
yorks west
the pain is just incredible i never had
this pain before
for a terrifying time last week doctors
did not know if roxanne smith
was going to live or die the quebec
woman had contracted the b117 variant of
covid19
and was very sick she's only 24.
i have three kids the worst thing i can
think about
the caveat is to die because
my my kids may need their moms
it's something doctors across the
country have noted this
third wave fueled by highly infectious
variants is hitting
young people hard i'm with this
tube it's my feeding tube
um i can't eat
because i'm vomiting everything
my stomach is like paralyzed because of
kavin
doctors believe smith is now stable but
she's facing another two weeks in
hospital
and then a long road to recovery michael
hawkins
has now been sick for five months
hospice in november then re-hospitalized
at the end of january
i've had several strokes in my brain
excuse me as a result of code as well
hawkins isn't in his 20s but at 58 he's
certainly not elderly either
the anglican church bishop has only just
become eligible for the vaccine
and he worries about catching covet 19
again
i am concerned about catching one of the
variants especially at this stage
or being someone who a carrier of that
to others
both say they understand covid fatigue
but when smith saw people in montreal
protesting culvert restrictions last
weekend
she felt angry too this variant
is very very affecting the young people
and now it's me
but after it will be another
teenager or young woman or a young man
a frightening reality facing much of the
country as covet variants continue
their rapid rise heather urex west
global news
calgary there's a growing outbreak of
coven 19 in nunavut
12 new infections were reported
overnight iqaluit now has 13 active
cases of the virus
nunavut's chief public health officer
says the new cases involve
several households all identified
through contact tracing
so far there is no evidence of community
transmission but cases are expected to
rise
the capital was put under strict
lockdown yesterday when the city's first
infection was confirmed
all schools non-essential businesses and
government offices
are closed a deadly confrontation
between
police and a teenager coming up the
killing of a boy that's reigniting
demands
for police reform
a gunman who opened fire at a fedex
facility in indianapolis killed eight
people
and wounded several others the shooter
then took his own life at the scene
and tonight investigators aren't clear
on the motive
there was no confrontation with anyone
that was there there was no disturbance
there was no argument
he just appeared to randomly start
shooting
it happened late last night the gunman
opened fire in the parking lot before
entering the building
the shooting was over in a matter of
minutes police say the 19-year-old
suspect was a former employee
at the facility we're learning more
tonight about a deadly shooting
in chicago and a warning the details and
video in this next story
are disturbing police body cam footage
shows a 13-year-old boy with his hands
in the air
an officer then fires a shot and kills
the teen
this latest case comes as the u.s is
still reeling from another fatal
shooting at the hands of police
in minnesota and as jackson proskow
explains both
incidents are leading to calls to
rethink police training
19 seconds after responding to a report
of shots fired
the officer encountered 13 year old adam
toledo
that single gunshot to the chest was
fatal
another camera angle appears to show
toledo put his hands behind a fence
before turning towards the officer
police released this image which they
say shows the teen
was carrying a gun a weapon can be seen
on the ground in body camera footage
the family lawyer says the teen's hands
were up and empty when he was shot
that child was given a directive he
complied
he surrendered he turned to the officer
with his hands up
and then he was shot overnight
protesters took to the streets of
chicago demanding reform
we demand justice while in minneapolis
where the community is still reeling
from the police shooting of dante wright
families demanded accountability how do
you keep having murder after murder
we don't have time to recover across
north america
policing is under the microscope like
never before law enforcement officers
are human beings
they can make mistakes the rapid rapid
condition mistakes often
steve somerville is a retired toronto
police officer and an expert in use of
force and de-escalation
he agrees there's room for change that
will save lives
this extremely difficult profession one
that i think we need to look at training
to perhaps define an officer's role in
attending these calls
in washington there are calls for
congress to pass the george floyd act
to better track officer misconduct and
mandate improved training around
racial bias that can put in place long
overdue reforms
that are necessary none of that will
change the horror that so many families
have gone through
nor will it repair generations of
mistrust between police
and so many of the communities they
serve
jackson prosko global news washington
still ahead no answers no trust a year
after the mass killing
in nova scotia
this sunday marks one year since the
massacre in nova scotia
the shooting spree is one of canada's
worst mass killings
22 people died now a public inquiry into
how a gunman
calculated and carried out the 13-hour
rampage
aims to prevent a similar tragedy from
happening again
but there's been a long period of
silence from officials and families are
struggling to put their trust
in the process ross lord reports
don and frank galenchin had just started
what they hoped would be a dream
retirement
in porto pick when they were murdered
along with 20 other nova scotians
over the course of 13 hours one year
later
don and frank's family members are
stricken by grief and bewilderment
maybe nothing could have saved anybody
in that immediate area
but to sleep six hours later
you know 30 minutes away wake up dude
all over again it's
that's how how
how can that happen rcmp say the gunman
slipped past them
and drove out of port-a-pick in his
mocked up rcmp vehicle
by using a different road than the one
they were guarding
but other information such as why an
emergency alert was never issued
remains murky after a series of erratic
news conferences
the rcmp promised more details from
their investigation
we commit to providing timely and
accurate updates
in the coming days and weeks that
promise 10 months ago
was the last time investigators faced
questions from the media
in a public setting the federal and nova
scotia governments have established a
public inquiry
headed by a mass casualty commission the
commission has been assigned to
investigate a wide range of questions
including
why the massacre happened and how police
responded
the commission says its final report due
in november of next year
will include recommendations for
preventing anything similar from
happening again
for families who were forced to protest
in the streets for a full public inquiry
trusting the process is a big leap of
faith they want more information
including details of the alleged role of
the gunman's common law partner lisa
banfield
in supplying him with ammunition police
say banfield and two others facing
charges had no prior knowledge of the
killer's plan
my trust in the inquiry and my trust in
the rcmp as a whole there's
there's none they wonder what has
changed
there are new measures including a ban
on assault rifles
on the sale of decommissioned police
vehicles and restrictions on used
uniforms
but other measures haven't happened
including a buy back on military-style
assault weapons
and reducing the smuggling of firearms
across the canada u.s border
public safety minister bill blair's
office has declined multiple requests
for an interview
and some say the collective silence with
no official date for when the inquiry
starts hearing evidence
deepens the level of mistrust you know
there was a failure by the state to
protect its citizens so
out of that alone you know it is you
know
a whole range and depth of suspicions
that are justifiable
he suggests it could take a long time to
pivot from trauma
to trust ross lord global news great
village nova scotia
and continuing with that tragedy
tomorrow night on the new reality
donna friesen talks to gary clement one
of the leading authorities on policing
in canada
on the crisis of confidence facing the
force
you know the circumstances in puerto pic
the horrible crimes
the gunmen committed were unlike
anything
we'd seen in canada have we learned from
that
now do you think would a response be
different if something so horrific was
to happen again today
we got to realize the rcmp cannot be all
things to all people and if we're going
to be more effective
we really should be honest with
ourselves recognize that
maybe it's time that we let provincial
and municipal
governments have deal with the policing
issue in their own backyard
and let the rcmp deal with the federal
very much like fbi or the drug
enforcement administration
united states and you can watch the full
report tomorrow night with donna friesen
on the new reality
right here on global up next the royal
plans to keep two brothers apart
at their grandfather's funeral
you're watching global national
prime minister justin trudeau spoke with
the queen today to offer his condolences
following the passing of prince philip
trudeau noted the special relationship
the duke of edinburgh maintained with
canada over the years
including his close ties with the
canadian armed forces
philip will be laid to rest tomorrow
during a funeral he largely planned
himself
it'll be a pared-down affair because of
covet restrictions
the queen and philip's children will be
front and center
but the drama between two of their
grandchildren isn't going
unnoticed our europe bureau chief
crystal gomansing
is in windsor tonight
on the eve of prince phillips funeral
his youngest child prince edward
and his family took in the tributes in
bright bouquets
left as a sign of respect guys
we've got the greatest respect for the
royal family
the queen and of course the duke of
edinburgh was
part of our lives maybe we're not seeing
him around with them anymore yeah
prince philip lived 99 years and in that
time he outlined
exactly how he wanted his funeral to
unfold
and who would attend kovit 19 has
changed some of those plans
only 30 mourners will be allowed to
attend the service compared to the
original list
of roughly 800. three of his german
family members
will be in attendance in addition to his
children
and grandchildren prince william and
prince harry are pulling focus
the brothers won't be walking side by
side behind their grandfather's coffin
instead their cousin peter phillips will
walk between them
i count myself as fortunate brigadier
general paul
doyle will be the lone canadian behind
the castle walls on saturday
i am privileged and i am humbled and i
am just you know
so proud to be able to to be there
to represent all of us prince philip
wanted representatives from the canadian
armed forces at his funeral
he often spoke of serving alongside
canadians during the second world war
his years of service reflected in the
customized
army green land rover that will carry
his coffin
crystal gomencing global news windsor
england
and we'll have live coverage of the
funeral tomorrow starting at 9am eastern
on globalnews.ca
and the global tv app and that is global
national for this friday night i'm robin
gill
tonight your canada is the bay of quinte
in ontario
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
you